[Music]
okay so let's move to Trump then anchors
I think what you said there's an
interesting segue to Trump so there
seems to be this feeling that the white
supremacist back there back in business
and white lawyers about it run so I saw
this you see this video of this guy
Richard Spencer who's the alright guy
you gotta getting punched he got punched
I tweeted out that I this guy has
obviously bad ideas I've had family
members on both sides of my family
killed in the Holocaust so I am NOT a
Nazi sympathizer in any way but I have
to defend his right to free speech
without being punched because that's the
whole point
you can't just defend it when TV you
gotta defend it when you don't want it
when that but I saw a lot of people on
the list a lot of famous people a lot of
people with a lot of influencing know
it's okay to punch Nazis which if you
just follow their logic through well he
could have killed him because you could
accidentally kill somebody and then if
it's okay to punch a random person
because of their beliefs could we blow
up his car can we bomb this house I mean
this is it this is a terrifically
slippery slope right of course it is is
it okay for me to burn up a building
because I'm unhappy with because of the
way the police treat me are why it's
perfectly okay would be okay if somebody
walked up to John Lewis and punched him
because they feel that John DeLucie have
attended the Donald Trump inaugural
where do we where do we go with this are
you kidding me
yeah and and believe me it would have
been a huge story if that had been
somebody like John Lewis who's been
punched as opposed to this Spencer guy
that the media doesn't care about and
feels is loathe them I understand that
but I would have thought there would
have been a little more coverage of it
but there wasn't very much yeah so I
know a certain amount of people are
going to watch this and go wait a minute
wait a minute here's a black guy and a
Jew somehow defending a Nazis right to
free speech he wants to I'm pretty sure
he'd want to kick both of us out of the
country and its are something close to
that but it's tough to have principles
right isn't that because that's the crux
of what you're saying basically the
through line of all this is you got to
have some principle wasn't it Voltaire
who say that I guess we what you said
but I would defend to my death your
right to say it I mean we're talking
about principles here yeah free speech
so yeah and by the way it's not unlawful
to hate somebody you can hate somebody
as you pointed out earlier you can't put
your hand on that person but you have
every right to dislike somebody for
whatever
reason you want yeah so I sense that a
lot of people think though that white
supremacy is back that they that they
feel that there was a link to Trump
somehow I don't really see that link but
that there was a link that somehow he
unearths this and now Pepe the Frog
robbed a the monkey and the white
supremacist they've been unearthed and
now they feel it's okay so there are
only responses to hit back I would argue
which I think you would argue which is
you beat them with better ideas let this
idiot talk and guess what he's going to
show what a fraudulent bigot he actually
is right um but do you think there's any
resurgence of actual like super embassy
I mean is that a real issue I'm not
saying it Donald Trump got a higher
percentage of the black vote the Mitt
Romney did and John McCain did he got a
harpes and Hispanic vote that Mitt
Romney did he got a smaller percentage
of the white vote than his uh his
criticism is that they were publicly ran
before him so I'm not seeing it I am
seeing a resurgence in the assertion
that white supremacy is back but I'm not
seeing it look one of Donald Trump's
surrogates was dr. ben Carson is dr. ben
Carson somebody that's going to cozy up
to somebody who's a white supremacist
one of my friends Steven Miller is the
young speech writer who wrote Donald
Trump's inaugural speech and rode his
RNC speech in about thirty in his early
30s I'm nineteen fifty was a teenager he
is not somebody's going to work for it
for a white supremacy happen to be a Jew
yeah so Donald Trump's a wrong vehicle
to take that on and John Lewis said that
he was not going to attend his
inauguration the first time in all of
his years being in Congress he's not
going to attend the presidential
inauguration false 50 he he did not
attend george w bush's inauguration yeah
now with george w bush a nazi was he up
with via fascist with he racist
what was your argument mr. lewis if you
were here at ask him for not attending
george w bush in his inauguration
i understand donald trump but claimed
george w bush's to me right so is that
the crazy position that a lot of people
have painted themselves into now they
screamed and ranted and raved the Trump
and this whole movement is vile and
racist and all this stuff
where now if he does any good they're
going to have to lash out in crazy ways
because you can't have a guy that you've
been calling Hitler for a year suddenly
you can't suddenly admit that he's doing
some good stuff right so they put
themselves in a really tight
intellectual box here I think they have
and again Donald Trump is a bad vehicle
to do that with because if you look at
some of his points of view they're quite
populist and quite left-wing he and
Bernie Sanders were completing each
other's sentences on free trade and when
Donald Trump had the interview with 60
minutes and he was asked about same-sex
marriage he said it was federal law he
could have said the same thing he said
about abortion which was I'm going to
put on a justice who ultimately would
turn over all the weight he didn't say
that
but that's really what he wants to
happen but he could have said that
regarding gay marriage because gay
marriage is less settled law than
abortion abortion has been on the book
since 1973 the gay marry decision just
now came down so your argument is that
he's actually more for a gay marriage
yeah then he is for abortion yes gay
marriage he said to steve Kroft that
issues been settled really he could have
said I'm going to put on justices that
will look at the Constitution and we'll
have all these issues go back to the
states like abortion but he didn't he
said same-sex marriage is settled law
which was his way in my opinion of
signaling to all of the people in the
country especially his critics that I am
okay with same-sex marriage and on if I
mention on and on free trade he and
Bernie Sanders were are identical and on
infrastructure he wants a
trillion-dollar infrastructure
investment a Chuck Schumer just now said
that he's okay with that yeah when you
have Chuck Schumer smiling it seems to
me you I'd be worried but the point is
this is these are fun kinds of things
yes and they felt that Obama's stimulus
was too small and this is bigger than
that so they're they're giddy over all
over all that so why Donald Trump is
engendering all this hostility when he
have so many centrist if not left-wing
points of view is beyond me well I think
it has to do with just the way he speaks
I think you know my concern about him
from day one as I've said a thousand
times on show I don't know what he's
moral centered but I don't know that you
know what a lot of these guys moral
Center is at the end of the day a lot of
them speak a lot clearer so you know you
think you know it right and then you
don't know it you probably argue that
about
but for Trump I don't know what it is
that being said I think the answer to
your question is I think the left no
longer has the ability to understand the
difference between words and actions so
they see his gruff language and some
poorly phrased things in it he speaks
not that well and then they think that
translates into action when in fact he
actually did a lot of things that
brought them more Center I think it goes
back to what we said earlier and that's
just a lack of critical thinking I think
when this are at the end of your name
all of a sudden there are certain sets
of views that people assume you have and
they go after those views you I look at
is his moral Center I look at Donald
Trump's family these kids adore him he's
had three different marriages
it's complicated pull all that stuff
together three different marriages
children from all three of the marriages
and they all get along and they all
worship their father how bad a guy can
be you know it's funny I had Donald
Trump jr. on my Sirius XM show talking
about how he was for gay marriage is
about a little bit before got passed
about let's say three years ago four
years ago talking about how he
personally before gay marriage even
though his dad wasn't and that his dad
said you go out and tell people whatever
you want so I thought that was that's
actually a nice marker of sort of what a
father should be do you fear his
authoritarian side well because that he
said small-l libertarian so you want the
government to scale back I sense he is
going yeah he's going to lower taxes and
they're already doing some stuff with
regulations that you're probably pulling
that kind but do you sense there could
be an authoritarian side even
controlling what businesses can do
overseas and that kind of stuff that you
may not like there are there are things
he said that I don't like I don't know
that I would label them authoritarian I
would label them as stupid for example
you're saying I'm going to put on a 30
or 40 percent tariff on goods that come
in from this country if you left the
country started a factory all you're
doing is discriminating against cheap
prices and hurting American consumers I
as a business person has an obligation
to maximize shareholder return and if my
biggest cost is labor and I can go
somewhere else and build my widgets for
less money I have an obligation to do
that and if I don't do that my
competitor will and for a businessperson
like Donald Trump to tell another
businessperson I'm going to punish
you for seeking profits to me is
outrageous I understand and support his
idea that a lot of the reasons people go
overseas because we have owners
regulations and high corporate tax once
you lower the regulations and lower the
corporate taxation and I as a CEO have
made a calculation that I can make more
money by putting my factory in a third
world country how dare you protects me
for doing that will give you the right
to do that right so you would basically
argue that if you lowered the corporate
tax rate did everything you could
unregulated ear you wouldn't need that
tax on the overseas stuff that's because
it would be humming and purring nicely
here what you wouldn't you wouldn't need
to leave the country
cut up a factory because you stay here
what we have right now are all these
environmental rules and regulations
designed to fight climate change we have
a very high corporate tax rate the
highest in the industrialized world you
deal with those kinds of things and
you'll take away the incentive that some
CEOs have to move outside the country
but some when you take all those away
you lower the lower the the regulatory
burdens that CEOs have to deal with and
they still want to put a factory
somewhere you have absolutely no right
to stop them from doing that yeah in my
opinion do you think it's hilarious how
we look at certain companies that do the
exact same things as other covey summer
okay some are sober example Trump made
his ties in Mexico which I kept saying
all along this isn't something you're
getting money you're proving the point
he's proving the point that it's cheaper
to do their change the regulations and
then he wouldn't have to at the same
time a company and Trump was mocked
relentlessly for doing that right at the
same time Apple designs their stuff in
Cupertino as they say and it's all made
in China and they hide all kinds of
stuff tax wise but we're all walking
around with iPhones how come some
companies are able to is that's just a
cool factor of Apple I think so and I
think Al Gore was on the board of
directors of Apple at one point I think
if he isn't now
and here they are manufacturing stuff in
China yeah some companies have better PR
than other companies he also sold
Current TV to Al Jazeera which is owned
by a Qatar one of the biggest exporters
of oil in the world but right now but
yeah we digress I dwell on that's right
okay let's let's move over to fake news
because I this is so tied into what's
happening with
krump the outrage machine and then the
fake news machine all of this you've
been all over this I am just a pocket of
PAP apoplectic I'm apoplectic about
what's going on with this because I see
the mainstream media crumbling I see
online media growing but I see risks in
that too because anybody can put on a
tie and pretend they're somebody and get
a desk and that you know it is what it
is how bad is this scourge of safety I
think we've always had really bad fake
news it just got passed off as CBS NBC
or ABC there have been lots of stories
in my opinion had been fake news stories
one of them was when Obama was pushing
Obamacare he said over and over again
that his mother who was suffering from
cancer as she lay dying on a hospital
bed in Hawaii had to fight with her
insurance carriers to pay for her
medical bills and her hospital bills
turns out it is not true he said it over
and over and over again a book came out
by woman named Jani Scott used to work
with the New York Times therefore it
must be a good book and she said that
those bills were promptly paid the only
quarrel was that Obama's mom had taken
out a policy so that if she got sick she
would be entitled to money and the the
law is that if you have been diagnosed
and you try to take a policy out like
that we can we can challenge it and
that's what they challenge but regarding
her medical bills hospital bills they
were paid promptly but he said it over
and over and over again and it helped to
drive a narrative that if my mother got
jacked over and she has a PhD and has a
son from Harvard with a law degree
imagine what these insurance carriers
will do to you it turns out completely
completely not true another fake news I
said I think I said earlier when Obama
said during his many press conferences I
am most proud of the fact that I rescued
the economy really tarp was done by
george w bush the bailouts were done by
george w bush and many of the things
that obama has done including stimulus
actually hurt the recovery didn't help
it yet he says it's over and over again
with a straight face and the failure of
the media not to ask challenging
questions when he raises that to me is
fake no so that's me so not to split
hairs there but that's the issue that
we've had basically a lap dog media so
there's the idea I think when when the
left talks about big news they're
talking about these
wing sites that are just making up
things right they push a lot of that on
Breitbart we can talk about that if you
want but that's different than what
you're talking about which is just a
media that just simply got cozy they got
cozy with the people in power so they
just stopped doing their job you're
calling that fake news
absolutely czar two separate types of
fake absolutely well I talked earlier
about Obama completely completely out of
Iraq over the objection of his of his
team he also then said well the reason I
did that is because George W Bush had
negotiated a an agreement that required
me to leave at the time I did completely
not true George W Bush did negotiated an
agreement but he fully expected his
successor to negotiate a stay behind
force and again Obama has said this over
and over again and the media hasn't said
anything about that that to me is fake
news right so I remember when that
happened and I remember thinking when
Obama said it yes they had they had set
the date but obviously Obama had plenty
of political capital at the time if he
had wanted to stay he could have stayed
so that's right this is just it's just a
conflation of poor media practices and
we saw a lot of this with Hillary right
just poor media practice and good night
the will apology show willingness it was
my the willingness to look the other way
because it's a guy that you're pulling
for yeah when Obama came into office he
reneged on a deal that george w bush had
negotiated he negotiated a deal with
poland and with the czech republic to
for them to get missile defense russia
didn't like it
obama thought that he could curry favor
with russia by remaking on the deal and
he did the failure of the media to bring
this up and to bring up him saying him
pushing the reset button and him saying
to Medvedev when I get reelected I have
more I'll have more flexibility the
failure of the media to bring this up
when they're hitting Donald Trump for
being too cozy with Putin is another
example of fake news yeah so that to me
is the monster that we've created they
did nothing for so long now because they
don't like Trump they're trying to be
professional services which I want them
to write I want them to do true
investigative journalism I want them to
fight the power but they seem almost
ridiculous doing it now because they're
watching tweets and getting outraged
before a weekend right I just wrote a
call about all of this and what I said
is the media has we discovered their
mission now that
Republican is back in the White House
yeah but before that in my opinion they
didn't do their jobs
yeah is it almost too late for them have
a because I think they've lost so much
cred that even now is they Scully to get
their credit back I mean for example
yesterday the day before I watched the
second Sean Spicer press conference not
not the quick one where he was bickering
about the first official I watched the
first official and I think it was Monday
right and I watched the entire thing I'm
doing cardio the only way I can watch it
right I got it you had a run from the
bush right so I'm watching this thing
okay
I thought he basically did a pretty
decent job he took a gajillion question
he answered them in pretty much the same
way that all press people do which is
you know half answer and partially I
move around that's what they do but
suddenly I saw the headlines
first up the the main Twitter moment
headline was saying that he was focusing
on the numbers of people there that was
just a small portion and it was only
because they kept asking him that same
question right so that's also fake news
right where they just keep framing
something a certain way not just that
not just what he said but that you can
take an hour and a half thing and though
well this was the part that was
important when you know it actually
wasn't the part let me say a couple of
things about that spicer not only
quarrel with the idea that Trump's
audience was larger than what the media
reported he also talked about the fact
that a reporter from Time magazine not
not the bucktussle Gazette Time magazine
said that Donald Trump removed the bust
of MLK from The Oval Office now that to
me is a major story if it were true it
is not true Time magazine a report of
Time magazine tweeted it and it went
around the world rather than focus on
that fake news part they talk about what
Sean Spicer said about the crowd size
because that's something they could
probably make an argument about at the
MLK thing they can't make an argument
about that so we haven't talked about
that yeah and we found out because of
WikiLeaks they how many of these
reporters were in bed with the DNC
invent with Hillary I mean a New York
Times reporter is doing a massive story
on Hillary and and gave her veto proof
over quote she doesn't like
a power that she that she in fact used
and took out a quote that she made about
Sarah Palin
yeah you're not making this up by the
way watch it Washington Post was doing a
story on John Podesta and found out some
conflict of interest regarding money and
and gave him a heads up and told him
don't worry about it we'll bury it in
the in the story staffers for a Jake
Tapper and for Wolf Blitzer of CNN
contacted the DNC and said we're about
ready to interview some Republicans have
any questions for us dana Milbank is the
columnist with The Washington Post he
did a story a column called the ten most
outrageous things Donald Trump has ever
said he contacted the DNC and said I've
already do this column on the ten most
outrageous things Donald Trump ever said
do you have any suggestions they gave
him ten suggestions he used eight yeah
are you kidding me you didn't even
mention the most egregious one in my
opinion which is the whole Donna Brazile
thing which is to me the heart because
that one is the heart of how corrupt
media and politicians have become but at
least CNN fired her but to B&C hired her
as interim chair even after she was out
of his having conspired with Hillary to
make sure that Bernie Sanders didn't do
that win so whatever they but a moment
but I think the motor
one of the most outrageous ones is a guy
named Kurt I can Wald yeah he writes for
Newsweek and tweet it that Donald Trump
had been put in a mental institution for
some time no evidence for it whatsoever
he took the tweet down pretty quickly
when it was debunked but he wasn't fired
or even spent or even shaft eyes so this
is where people talk about Pope's
troops now I know we don't want to be in
a post redesign what's closed true but a
little post true that at this point you
know any idiot who's amassed one hundred
fifty thousand Twitter followers had as
much influence in a lot of respects as
new swamp along with $150 yeah make it
make it make you for calling me an idiot
I just want others that's why I
mentioned that number about any idiot
that I would have as much influence but
but really you could have a set you
could figure out how to do the social
media game and somehow because of that
you got a little blue check to now now
you're an authority on this stuff and
they're so that I do see is a major risk
that while I wanted the mainstream media
to to get the lashing it deserved the
fact that it's now everyone's just
picking their truth wherever they
find it is a huge problem if it's both a
problem and a blessing it also means
that the the traditional establishment
media can be can be gone around you can
get your ideas out and and nothing can
stop you from communicating to people
but you're right it means that anybody
can communicate and whether or not he or
she is credible is left to you as a
consumer to figure out is there any way
that you think Trump can reconcile this
relationship with the media because I
think it's it's almost the most
important thing right now more important
than the policies because it's one thing
to just rail against the media all the
time again I don't like what the media
the mainstream media have done but do
you think you can get to a point where
he'll actually do some real sit downs do
some real press conferences and not do
the same things you know be willing to
sit down with an interviewer hopefully
it'll be me but maybe it'll be somebody
else and not demand the questions in
advance you know be better than all the
reasons that you just said the Democrats
well III don't I don't think it's Donald
Trump's job to to curry favor with the
media I think it's the media's job to be
fair and as far as I'm concerned he has
very little risk
he is disliked more than Reagan more
than george w bush in my opinion they're
out to get him and for him to have a
more confrontational attitude towards
the media to me makes perfect sense
because there is no upside in him doing
it any other way
they're going to go after him like
nobody's business yeah I guess they just
like him because of his attitude about
about immigration they think of him as a
racist I think of him as a bigot as a
tyrant if that's your attitude and
you're not going to cut me any slack
why should I kiss your butt so I have no
problem with what Sean did his Shawn
spiced for his first informal press
conference when he when he blasted the
media the way he did and it does turn
out that Donald Trump audience which is
the word he used to watch the Nardo was
bigger than any audience in history in
part because of social media right so a
lot of people on Twitter were angry made
over that cuz I didn't say anything
about it but if you listen to actually
what he said he said audience meeting
tea and then he clarified
he said I mean people that are streaming
it on Facebook and watching on iPads and
you said already done but everybody
wants everyone to get outraged all right
I'm it's exhausting isn't it also turns
out apparently that when you look at the
the the pictures of Obama's inaugural
and Trump's Trump's does look thinner
but my understanding is part of that is
because of security measures there's
certain places you can't stand anymore
certain place you can't go through any
more so a lot of people couldn't get to
the main area because of all the
security requirement so you're comparing
not apples to apples and so if you'd
agree all that is just sideshow nonsense
right like it's actually completely
irrelevant whether the amount of people
I talk about not relying about it but
just together they were X amount of
people or Y it's just you know
completely irrelevant except that he's
putting media on notice that you have to
be fair to me
yeah do you think the media regrets you
know it's hard to categorize all the
media but when they look back at the way
they treated McCain who now looks like
the most moderate Republican of all time
you know and they they they were times
calling him racist and I think he has an
adopted black daughter and I'm not
mistaken or when they look at Romney and
the binders of women and made it sound
like he hates women
but they in a way they created Trump
because any Republican was going to get
the cries of races and was going to get
the cries of misogyny and the cries of
xenophobia and homophobia and all that
so he brings up Peter Thiel he still
hates gays he might has been cars that
he still lays Blacky right so in a way
he was the only answer to this absurd
equation right I think you're right I
think the media did could be helped to
create Donald Trump people resent the
idea that the media had gone after
Republicans in a way that they not gone
after Democrats and so there's a
distrust and when Donald Trump talked
about political correctness and how he's
no longer going to be politically
correct a lot of people took that to
mean I'm no longer going to going to
seat thinking of myself as a racist as a
sexist simply because I've got normal
views and normal ideas any other guy has
and I think Donald Trump has given
people like that a certain amount of
comfort and credibility yeah all right
so one more forea which will sort of
wrap this whole thing up what happens
over the next four years where do you
really see this all going do you see
this endless
clash between between Trump and the left
is there a way to get the media
straightened out should we get some of
the societal stuff to shake out or is it
just going to be more battling because
it seems I thought there was going to be
a couple days after the election where
everyone we take a breath right it seems
like everyone's just ramping up more and
more now know people see things
differently we disagree we disagree
about abortion we disagree about
same-sex marriages to be about taxes
about spending about foreign policy as
long as we have those disagreements
we're going to have these kinds of
disputes but I think what will happen
hopefully is that we have four percent
GDP growth like we did under Ronald
Reagan Ronald Reagan was overwhelmingly
reelected not because people agreed with
him they disagree with him about his
nuclear proliferation they disagreed
about his going into South America and
trying to roll back some of the
communist movements there
if you go down list by list of the
article in The New York Times in 1986
and talked about all of these points of
views and how Americans disagreed with
Ronald Reagan but they respected him and
overwhelmingly re-elected him because
ultimately it comes down to the economy
comes down to pocketbook and seventy
percent of the American people felt that
we were on the wrong track economically
and that is the primary reason in my
view why Donald Trump won worst economic
recovery since 1949 this has been a 2
percent recovery the average recovery 3
percent and the difference between 2%
and 3% is 1 million jobs times at least
the recovery so if Obama had done
nothing had worked on his putting we had
7 million more jobs than we have right
now yeah well he did work on the Buddy
yeah we'd have 10 million more Larry was
a pleasure we're gonna do a little bode
segment for ok audience and I thank you
for coming back pleasure and we're going
to link to the original one and people
can see if maybe I changed you in some
ways to who knows well I felt I felt the
same way leaving as I bill coming
ok all right Laura Larry check out his
website larry elder com
[Music]
you